they decided they didn't want to use
those stories they decided they were
going to go do their own thing and so I
decided fine but basically I'm not going
to try to
they weren't that Keen to have me
involved anyway but at the same time I
said I'm not gonna if I get in there I'm
just gonna cause trouble
because they're not going to do what I
want them to do so I don't have the
control to do that anymore and all I
would do is muck everything up so I said
okay
I will
go my way and I'll let them go their way
[Music]
but I knew there's three more stories
and I knew that was going to probably
take you know to do it right would take
about 10 years and I said I'm 70.
I don't know whether I'll be here when
I'm 80. you know every 10 years the odds
get less and uh so I said
and I'm not ready to do that because I
want to do these other things so I have
to make the decision on my own that it's
time for me to move on